as soon as it came through the door from
the inner rooms and I saw the casket
would you mind us going through the
timeline of what happened from the
moment they found out he's dead to the
moments because that's where that's
where the challenges with this story
right I mean you try autopsies I've been
challenged for me when I look at it I'm
a numbers guy so first they find out
he's dead
boom checkmark then they say let's put
his body they wrap him up in a nice they
put him in a really nice casket they
take him to Air Force One that's number
two Lyndon Johnson's waiting there
rather than going back to DC to have the
body being delivered to the plane which
is kind of a little bit wild for that
gets to Air Force One then they fly back
to Bethesda DC they land they take that
nice casket and they put it in the
automobile that Jackie Kennedy is
writing you to go to where you're at the
morgue
they arrive actually at 7:30 but the
body doesn't come in to 717 and the body
doesn't come in till 8:00 and the
challenge that I'm seeing there is
another automobile delivers cascade
that's used for Vietnam veterans back in
the days just to GP topic ask it that
apparently they took John F Kennedy and
they put him in a body bag and they put
him there that was brought to you guys
at around 6:00 at 6:30 they had an hour
and a half before 8:00 o'clock so that's
the part that's completely cure see and
again - I really don't have any insight
into that either report the boys young
report and yeah all of that the numbers
him and Dennis David's timing and seeing
this I had to have a timeline for this
as I was writing it I had no personal
timeline because you know all I saw was
the body rewriting and in what I
consider to be a shipping casket that
was striking in the fact is that it was
the president's body in that in that
such a ordinarily you saw that yes yes I
saw the shipping cast yes I did and
that's not typical protocol to put a
president under shipping casket I
wouldn't think so you wit
yes I saw check marking that time well
you saw that part
yeah the casket came in and it was
brought in by by people they were in
business suits mm and they may have been
a couple of military officers with it
but they were brought it was brought in
and it was brought into the more proper
sat down on the floor Paul helped them
take the body out and they put the body
on the table in front of me now I've you
I'm used is Dennis Davis time line and I
use it because sergeant of origins
action report stated 635 several years
ago we talked to an individual his name
and was well he was dr. J Scott I
believe and he's told us that he was the
officer of the day for the protesser
hospital during the conversation was
with William law William asked him what
time the kind of the body came in and he
immediately said 6:30 so I took sergeant
Boren and dr. Scott as collaboration for
the time that Dennis quoted and then I
used that time as a lie as a timeline
for the autopsy at that point in time I
had memories but I I wasn't quite sure
of sequencing of them and then over the
three years that I've been writing this
book I basically just write sections and
certain things and so forth and then
each section would begin to support or
ask or create questions about that
particular memory the timeline that I
use like I said is is Genesis that
timeline gave me the ability to say the
body was here at 6:30 when when the body
was put on the table everybody was asked
to leave the body was still it was on
the table is still wrapped in the sheets
had anybody was separate and then dr.
Boswell left morgue for I don't know 15
20 minutes maybe and
I just assumed he was going back up to
the laboratory to you know talk to dr.
Humes and while the body's in front of
you yeah the body is in the morgue and
the morgue what Paul and I this is what
time I assumed that had to be somewhere
between 6:30 and 7:00 o'clock if I say
it took him approximately 10 minutes to
unload the body from the Hurst and bring
it to to that because see Dennis in his
his group or his his crew they did not
bring him into the morgue they brought
it to the morgue door according to
Dennis and then someone back yeah and
somebody took it from there the morgue
was set up where there was little any
room that had Coll boxes where he would
put the bodies to me and then then it
came into the morgue proper so let me
ask you from the moment it was delivered
to the morgue from the back not the one
with Jackie Kennedy that arrived around
7:30 to 8:00 o'clock I'm talking to one
that arrived early
from that moment word showed up in that
cheap casket to the moment where you saw
it what was that time line I would say
probably no more than five minutes okay
because you just was unloaded onto the
to the dock and then brought into the in
through the double doors and then mork's
mmediately to the left as soon as it
came through the door from the inner
rooms and I saw the casket and that's
when I that's what I remember and the
reason I remember that is the fact is
that it was such a plain casket you know
and and that was that struck me as being
that the president's body would be in a
in a transport casket now this entire
time Jackie's thinking the bodies and
ornate casket that she was driving in
that that's the one that's being
delivered I really owe my part that
would be conjecture or speculation